hélène buzzetti michel suau j michel
david bonsoir pourquoi un petit mot sur
jean yves duclos son annonce je le
disais on solidifie les défenses hélène
c'est un peu ça ça tout chambouler on
dit bon ben ce qui entre désormais vous
devrez vous faire tester à l'aéroport
sauf si vous oubliez des états unis oui
en même temps moi j'ai envie de vous
dire patrice mais qu en apprendrons-nous
leçon je ne comprends pas pourquoi on
n'arrive pas avec une mesure plus
musclée qui dirait que désormais
quiconque rentrer au canada vacciner
peut vacciner canadiens peuvent
actionner doit absolument se mettre à
quarantaine et subir un test quelque
part entre le 4e et le huitième jour
après son arrivée parce que on le sait
que les tests oui faire à l'entrée
admettons que la personne arrive dans un
pays et vient tout juste de contracter
la maladie un test fait dans les 24
heures ne sera pas suffisamment fiables
ça pourrait être un faux négatifs alors
qu'il faut attendre la période clé c'est
aux 4e et 8e jours alors je comprends
pas pourquoi on n'y voit pas une à une
approche par étapes et ça me semble une
bonne recette pour qu il soit trop
douvres oui ok michel st
moi je ne comprends pas l'exemption
américaine je la comprends parce qu on
est voisins des états unis puis les
relations commerciales et tout ça mais
en même temps quand on voit ce qui se
passe aux etats unis c'est un des
endroits du sud des états unis en
particulier un dea droit actuellement le
plus touché par par la commune en
général on verra ce qui arrive avec de
nouveaux variants mais c'est quand même
une dose de un droit de passage
si vous arrivez par exemple beaucoup sûr
que c'est le bon message en brie bon
j'en avais web et on avait reproché
beaucoup en 2020 au printemps dans le
mât fédéral de ne pas avoir réagi assez
vite alors là il se dit je vais agir
mais il y a avec des demi-mesures
il ya évidemment c'est incomplet c'est
mieux que rien mais je pense que c'est
simplement un premier pas moi je vois je
vois pas comment la situation d'un
adulte ne pourrait pourrait ne pas
dégénérer et les mesures qui sont
annoncées aujourd'hui sont à mon sens un
préliminaire la kia qui en annonce des
plus difficiles dans l'est dans les
prochains jours ou les prochaines
semaines il n est pas si vous avez
assisté à toute la conférence de presse
mardi le docteur nous a pris la parole
puis à 10 il serait illusoire de penser
qu'on peut fermer les frontières on
n'est plus là d'heures non verts vous
fait pas fléchir dans votre nom mais on
en a déjà parlé vous et moi on peut pas
fermer la frontière ne serait ce que des
canadiens ont tout à fait le droit de
rentrer dans leur propre pays so on est
tous d'accord là dessus mais ça ne veut
pas dire que on ne devrait pas se mettre
en quarantaine
monsieur david parle elle de peut-être
le premier peuple et je suis d'accord
avec lui si verso on va avoir un autre
pot il ya un autre pot mais ça fait en
sorte qu'on est toujours comme un pas
derrière on va toujours réagir quand on
va voir une augmentation des causes se
placer en quarantaine au retour d'un
voyage s'est pas beaucoup demandé de
passer un test au huitième jour c'est
pas énormément demandé mais ça éviterait
des contaminations par des gens qui est
en vacciner n'auront pas beaucoup de
symptômes seront peut-être pas qu'ils
ont qu'ils sont porteurs de ce variant
ils vont pouvoir comme seul disséminés
partout et pour ce qui est des à tout ce
qui est des états unis juste préciser à
ce qu'on nous dit en coulisse et qu' il
y aurait trop de monde ça représenterait
trop de monde on open à ses grandes
capacités de test et c'est pour ça cette
exemption je pose c'est vrai mais c'est
ce qu'on nous et puis un peu de
réciprocité le ferai pas le bon ok mais
très bien c'est réglé pour ça c'est pas
réglé mais je vous attends je vous ai
traduit pour noël monsieur legault si
elle à charlevoix moi j'aimerais que ce
soit 25 ans puis les gens les grandes
familles au québec encore parfois au
pied mais quelques heures afin son
ministre avait dit n'oubliez pas ces 10
personnes maximum
alors on va entendre ce que ç'a créé à
québec aujourd'hui
si on veut que les règles soient
respectées
on peut pas juste lancée dans l'ère des
souhaits comme ça c'est ce qui crée de
la confusion quand françois le goff fait
çà il prend les devants sur la science
en pandémie la politique devrait se
ranger derrière la science on me
demandait vous est ce que vous pensez
qu'il faudrait à supplée le nombre de
personnes des maisons j'ai dit que moi
j'étais ouvert un sommet que je me
fierais à santé publique si on peut plus
dire ce qu'on pense
on a un problème
ça nous a fait sourire jade avait bien
sûr qui peut dire ce qui par mais quand
le premier ministre dit à haute voix ce
qui paraît donc sa plus forte quand vous
parlez ou quand je parle de quoi il peut
dire ce qu'ils pensent mais est-ce pas
toujours bon de dire ce qu'on pense et
dans ce cas ci c'est un très bel exemple
là je me mets dans la peau du dr arruda
kisiwa mon patron là il veut absolument
car en face des parts à noël puis si je
l'interdis bas c'est lui qui va perdre
la face le alors ça ça met une pression
assez assez inconfortable
et si par exemple il juge que c'est
possible sans grand risque et qu'il
autorise on va tous se demander waimea
ce que c'est vraiment qu'ils pensent
qu'il n'y a pas de risque c'est parce
qu'il veut pas mettre son patron dans la
baraque et le lien de confiance il est
fondamental pour que les gens continuent
à suivre les mesures et si on se dit
basse gaulois il sert des intérêts
politiques le lien de confiance
avec les lib dems même si c'est fait de
bonne foi et sincèrement le doute va
s'installer
michel st les premier ministres aux
potes d'affaires avoir des états d'âme à
la fin ils gardent pour eux qui annonce
des choses on le fait ou on ne fait pas
les galets de tout à fait raison si
c'est
mission impossible à cause de ça mais
c'est des fois mais je le vois le
réflexe de vouloir être le bon gars
d'affaires comment j'aimerais ça on
avait ces personnes à noël oui mais le
1er mai nice-matin bongo twitter non
plus il ya des fois où ce il va causer
de la confusion ou causer des conflits
potentiels
je suis d'accord avec tout ce que mes
collègues on dit je pense que monsieur
legault en disant ce qu'il a dit on un
peu télégraphié ses intentions ceci dit
j'ai quand même confiance que monsieur
arruda est assez solide pour prendre ses
décisions et même s'il devait s'en tenir
à la règle actuelle des dix personnes je
suis pas certaine que ça ferait passer
monsieur legault pour si fou que ça
compte tenu de tous les revirements
auquel on a eu droit à noël pas si je
pense que monsieur legault est capable à
apprendre est ce que les gens vont
suivre le dissuade bon sur ce on est
loin d'être sûr mais l'homme en est
voilà
notre collègue gerbet lâche pas le
morceau info il veut donner sa gerbe et
une lâche pas le morceau les documents
que la coroner a demandé c'est pas les
bons de crise et des résumés qu'on a
envoyé la corner qui est long on s'est
assez vite ce que pense la phase iib
retrouver à la période de questions on
va faire écouter quelques échanges se et
l'on a appris qu'ils avaient 11 mail
fish qui vont finalement être envoyés en
écosse
les rapports d'inspection rempli
manuellement son où on peut en avoir
copie faut que j'ai dit sur ça peut pas
être plus clair que seuls les rapports
nombre de députés par les sons sur deux
sites web depuis longtemps monsieur
parce que c'est de l'information qui
était transparente à ça que ça sente
comme si on en kite contraint que la
personne a répondu commence à avoir des
nouvelles la commissaire à la santé et
au bien-être ont un mandat de s'occuper
de la performance du système mais à
trouvera pas les responsables les
familles éplorées veulent savoir qui est
responsable on veut reprendre ce
calmement très calmement je demanderai
aux députés de bien écouter ce que j'ai
dit non des deux premières parties de la
réponse
monsieur dubé dit ça existe les
documents sont disponibles là au delà de
ce que en faire moins que vous sachiez
puis de qui totalement raison c on voit
que l'opposition l'a a changé sont là
dessus puis ne lâchera pas le morceau
michel sauget sur la question d'abord de
la commission publique et on laissera
pas passer chaque détail ou c'est pas
clair
ils vont me laisse courir c'est à qui on
rend pas une commission
normal d'akale publiques comme celle
qu'on a vue dans d'autres domaines ça
c'est certain mais là il ya quand même
et notre collègue germain méritent
d'être félicités pour cela il ya quand
même
apparence au moins de vouloir cacher des
choses et c'est ça que le gouvernement
ne peut pas se permettre à ce moment ci
d'abord parce que mentir un grade est
aussi grave que mentir comme si on a
quelques public et puis je dis pas
qu'ils ont menti mais ça sent pas bon on
dirait que à une randonnée des résumés
parce que on voulait citer s'attache à
l'accord d'un nonce marche pour sow
alors c'est là dessus que quelques le
point sur l'offre pour puis n'ont pas
nécessairement menti mais comme vous
dites ça soulève un doute là y'a comme
un manque d'honnêteté de clarté michel
oui mais il ya surtout des versions
contradictoires à chaque fois le
gouvernement change sa version et ça
c'est évidemment de nature à semer le
doute au début il n'existait pas là ces
documents là maintenant on les range à
11000 alors il ya quand même une
évolution assez moins qu'on peut dire et
c'est pas des détails le nécessairement
le canton dit on fait un résumé bien par
définition résumé ça oublier un certain
nombre de choses or dans ces documents à
la et gerber qui en a consulté
quelques-uns notre qu'il ya des absences
des manques si on veut vraiment savoir
ce que le gouvernement au fait ou n'a
pas fait il faut la chronologie des
rapports faut que à telle date bon on a
constaté telle chose deux semaines après
il ya tout quelque chose qui a changé ou
non alors s'est il faut il faut déballer
les dents forest de détails et que ça
tout à fait c'est de cette forêt là
qu'apparaît le portrait général alors on
peut pas de la voir si on n'a pas les
touts les armes exactement oui moi
j'hésite entre être charitable il me
dira peut-être que c'est une erreur dans
leur l'entrée de données parce que il ya
tellement d des incongruités que
l'inspecteur dit je n'ai pas réussi à
trouver les réponses à la question 14 et
qu'un incident dans le résumé on donne
des réponses à ces questions 14 et 15
donc on peut se dire mon dieu le
gouvernement pense est il que la coroner
serait à ce point aveugle donc j'hésite
entre aide charitable et évidemment
signée qui me dira bien le gouvernement
assez de temps passer une petite vite
mais je suis assez d'accord avec michel
david en bout pis ces détails le sont
moins importants que la question plus
large et qu'est ce qu'on a fait avec ces
détails là avec ces rapports la cantine
et reese reçu hôtes ont agi sur
l'information qu'il contenait très bien
les éducatrices ont réussi ont gagné
leur pari ils vont pas assez de 19
premiers échelons à 21 dollars et de 25
et 18 pour l'échelon maximal à 30
dollars de l'heure c'est une
augmentation de 21 pour ça réussit là
vous vous dites pourtant demain ceux qui
nous écoutent demain qui ont des enfants
à ses pairs il ya une grève pour les 400
tpm qui sont syndiqués avec la sienne
parce que les autres employés autour on
le grave pas les augmenter autant l'idée
c'était de monter les éducatrices je
repose la question que j'ai posée à deux
semaines qui a le gros bout du bâton les
syndicats au le gouvernement dans ce
dossier là et les parents se retrouvent
cloués un peu
moi je pense que c'est dangereux pour
les syndicats on a tous beaucoup de
sympathie pour leur cause pour les
travailleuses mais je pense que les
parents qui l'ont si vous avez un enfant
à la garderie vous avez eu un début de
pandémie en 2020 extraordinairement
difficile à faire du télétravail avec
vos enfants sur sur les genoux les
parents de jeunes enfants ils sont
exténués sont taboues lots de voir
poindre une grève à l'horizon et je
pense qu'ils ne seront pas matin voilà
ça dépend lesquels
mais
évidemment je pense qu'ils vont avoir de
la difficulté à rallier leurs clients
terre dans le fond parce qu'ils sont
exténués et on comprend pourquoi d'une
arme à utiliser avec une prudence de
vous un michel c
c'est effectivement une arme est
utilisée avec prudence mais en même
temps la situation dans des cpa est
quand même difficile même si les
éducatrices ont eu une grosse
augmentation sont pas des grosses
équipes et un moment donné la cuisinière
qu'il n'aura pas eu la grosse
augmentation il met en avant tous les
jours l'affairé déroule aux locaux qui
faillirent pas et c'est ça qui aussi
motive les jeunes ils vont pas nous
utiliser les fonctions de get de rester
solidaires je pense que oui et c'est un
peu inévitable qu'il de faire cette
année que c'est des petites équipes
aucun michel david pour répondre à votre
première question qui a eu au bout du
bâton va éventuellement c'est le
gouvernement parce que si ça débloque
pas à brève échéance il va y avoir une
loi spéciale alors ça c'est gouvernement
qui va décider quand est-ce que ça va
finir mais la saaq on assiste ces
commandes est l'ultime bataille des
syndicats contre l'espèce de
d'hérésie
préféré gouvernement décide accès plus
vrai que tout le monde va avoir les
mêmes augmentations et ça ça passe mal
et on le voit là mais il faut dire que
dans un cpe tout le monde ne gagne pas
le même salaire alors c'est certain que
l'écart entre lille et catégories
d'emplois vont encore augmenter si le
gouvernement accorde 20 % au aux
éducatrices en seulement neuf à d'autres
catégories alors ça c'est doublement
chacun pour un syndicat pour ce qui est
des parents ils sont ils sont évidemment
pris en otage parce que là il faut se
trouver autre chose mais il ya une seule
d'arrêter un peu fort c'est aussi là
dedans ce à dire que les parents pour
bébés choix que d'être solidaire des
éducatrices qui rencontrent tous les
jockeys qui prennent soin de la sortie
de nouilles ils peuvent ils peuvent quoi
se retourner contre elle très bien merci
beaucoup à vous trois et on va suivre
l'évolution ou pas de monsieur duclos
pour les mesures mais je me souviens que
les trois lettres ou insuffisant il y en
a qui vont dire que c'est beaucoup déjà
de se faire tu essaies l'arrivée mais on
va suivre ce débat merci beaucoup bonne
soirée au revoir pour voir nos émissions
en entier rendez vous sur la chaîne ici
et redit